hey guys I'm Ryan Wright diam Danielle
Danielle one of my pet
are you and my best friends I am are we
like best friends status we are I think
we've kind of gone in there we have this
was a good moment I'm glad we got this
on camera
it was Danielle and I are gonna learn
how about how to have anal sex I can't
bring up derogatory sex jokes about my
girlfriend anymore her family doesn't
like it well you can same to me okay
thank you
that's why you're okay so by simple pick
up channel link in the description box
if you want to watch the video in full
screen and yeah let's do this
everybody likes the vanilla but
sometimes you want to try something a
little different yeah maybe you don't
want kids or maybe your religion doesn't
let you have sex before marriage most
people want to try anal but here's two
questions on everyone's mind one will it
hurt yeah will I get [__] on my dick
listen stop being so anal about anal
step one find the butt step two
Inspector Gadget make sure there's no
poop in there she can do this by making
sure rust is polished off the trombone
or if she's super anal she can use a
home enema kit these work by gently
squeezing water in time but that's how I
cleanse out clear it's like
interrogating a terror cell this [__]
you'll be sure it's not holding any
secrets step 3
lube it up to do this you should use
very very thick glue and lots of it the
absolute thickest Lube you can find I'm
talking about oh wow warm up enter the
premises with care and delicacy okay
it's like adding salt you don't want to
overdo it off the bat go slow and add
more when she's ready nice at first it
might hurt she might feel like she has
to pull but you have to trust me here
help her relax she won't poop probably
if she does don't worry neither of you
will ever
this again if you're the one giving the
gift of anal don't double dip the chip
you ever watched someone at a Super Bowl
party dip a chip bite it and then dip
again no one likes that and those are
just snacks when you're done clean up
with baby wipes then look at yourself in
the mirror you did it big guy
give yourself a thumbs up you just flat
[__] somebody hey guys make sure you
subscribe to our channel we're putting
out a new video every single week in
2016 then let us know in the comments a
topic you want to see next
I like this guy's channel subscribe to
simple pickup people that looks uglier
these are like disturbing and hilarious
yeah I've heard that thing before are
you know like we were talking about in
another video how we're Catholic and you
know how sex before marriage I used to
believe in that I used to believe sex
before marriage was the right thing to
do was it wasn't it's it's not the right
I mean no sex before marriage is the
wrong thing so you wouldn't have sex
before marriage I would it like that was
my old belief okay trust me that's
change people that's okay I'm not gonna
say this guy's name but there was this
Disney Channel star who I was friends
with it's not that one guy who I've
talked about before it was I was like
acquaintances with this other one and he
told me that he lost his virginity to
anal sex cuz his girlfriend didn't want
to lose her virginity I guess that is a
real thing out there where some people
think if you're having an to me you know
sex is like worse than vaginal
penetration I've had the experience of
anal sex in my life before and was it
like one of the best things in the world
and these are all great tips tips
biggest part will it hurt that's a big
question of course it'll especially if
you're new to it like I've never heard
of a girl doing it for the first time in
the butt and then being like yeah
actually you know that was easy piece of
cake yeah yeah okay so I was watch I saw
this porn the other day that this girl
did the record for having the most dicks
in someone's ass how many she had four
what were penises
she had three in all the way and then
one like when in like a second and got
one out see I wonder if outside of porn
people do that cuz when ice when I've
seen like triple penetration into porno
before it just looks like so hard and
I'm wondering how I would get off to
something like that in real life my guys
the guy is one of the three guys yeah I
don't I don't get it either yeah yeah
and then you can barely move yours like
yeah that's what I mean you could barely
move we all got it like work together I
don't know guys don't really do that at
real life yes oh you're saying guys yeah
probably
I'm sure just feel like to be funny one
time I surely do yeah maybe but I got
[__] on my dick
now that's honestly something I don't
think people should really be
embarrassed about believe it or not I'm
not gonna crack jokes at people in this
area because I've known a lot of women
to actually have done that and and
sometimes it's like usually early on and
I think that it's something you can move
past this is something I've experienced
personally no so I can't really talk
from it is this something I want to
experience of course not
but if I did experience it I would be
very kind
are you listening baby you don't watch
this channel she watches it
no she doesn't every time she does she
hates me well you can just do the old
trick of like having regular sex nothing
like oh there it is thanks Dan
accidentally no but you need a lot of
Lube like they were saying pinata line
bond and do a couple slide into the
badge and then just go just really oh
crap no I'm not gonna say oh crap when I
put my penis in someone's butt well then
you do it and then when she doesn't
freak out then everything's fine I
should you should
yeah it does feel different it doesn't
just feel like a tighter vagina it
doesn't know it feels like a different
type of thing that feels as equally good
as a vagina they were saying get an
enema done I've been thinking of getting
a hydro colonic cleanse you know where
you're like in there for an hour they're
just cleaning out all the toxins and
it's just coming out of your ass and
I've been thinking of doing that or you
could buy an enema now this is a great
idea if you're looking to have anal sex
I think really cleans you out you don't
have to worry about are you gonna [__]
during anal sex cuz you're really
getting a good cleansing enemas I hear a
great for your colon your kidney so it's
a plus all around multiple benefits you
need an enema for more than just anal
sex but if you're gonna do anal sex and
I'm light up I agree that's a hard thing
to say and I mutt it up and I man up
what are the PC muscles again because
sometimes she if she doesn't relax then
she might actually have to poop well
besides that I think it can like rip or
something right like something can
happen inside if you're super tense okay
okay
so yeah it'd be good to like smoke some
weed beforehand put some weed lubricant
on the Jade lubricant on the vagina
I have numbing cream you can use numbing
cream ooh interesting or just take a
bunch of pills
what do you mean like fiber pills no no
like vicodin and that'll make it easier
to not do it this is great healthy
advice today if you just load up just
take some prescription drugs take a
couple you'll just you won't go you only
didn't care what's going on to you at
that point
the life and story of Dan yeah
that's my helpful - ah brought back the
tip biggest bar kudos a simple pickup
again for doing another creative video
through visuals clearly a lot more work
than I put into this you know it's
awesome to see that you have millions of
followers I'm proud of you I'm proud of
you you are a good service to the
YouTube community anyway guys listen if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today become a reject you
might like it you can check out Danielle
on her Instagram you know like who
doesn't visit her Instagram my
girlfriend's visiting Instagram like
every time I'm like looking through my
girlfriend's phone like who she look it
up it's always Danielle always done
you'll have a catcher looking at
Danielle or touching herself to Danielle
and you know what it's totally okay
there's some good news right there
Mustang news I've heard all week I know
I've tried but like what I've tried
masturbating you I just I can't quite
focus disorder to send you a picture
just for you
you would do that what kind of picture I
got a good one yeah has to do with
peanut butter and a note
you can check her out on it